we talked a lot about Sterling I mean
Gil yields is just as dramatic if not
more so it absolutely is and let me show
you because I've got those gillians in
just a sec first of all though the pound
you know this is a pretty historic
moment um here we are this is just
showing you the last few days by the way
so we're going back to Thursday you can
see there that first bit is Thursday and
so we're just looking at kind of minute
by minute changes uh in the pound versus
the dollar bear in mind the dollar is
strong at the moment so there is a bit
of a dollar strength story here but
really from this budget speech onwards
is primarily all about the pound and
what is that story we'll have a look at
this there it went down after the speech
went off up for a teeny tiny bit you can
barely see it though it did go up a
little bit the government was saying oh
this is great news the voting confidence
for markets and then down down down down
down down and then today again in the
morning in early trading uh in Asia you
can see it went down very sharply again
it has started to bounce back and I you
know there may be some hope that it
starts to regain that level about 108 at
the moment but of course if we we kind
of just zoom back to where we were only
a couple of days ago you know it's come
down an awful lot since then so a big
fall in Sterling and bear in mind you
this what is this this is a kind of
measure of how much how much
enthusiastic enthusiasm there is from
people investors millions of investors
around the world to put money into the
UK or to take it out and it looks at the
moment like they're very much
withdrawing money rather than putting it
in and at the same time as the pound
being weak you have another chart where
things are going up and this is not the
kind of chart that you necessarily want
to see because this is government
borrowing yields this is the rate of
borrowing the government potentially has
to pay on its 10-year bond it's the
Benchmark measure here and this goes all
the way back where that last chart was
just over a few hours or a few days this
goes all the way back to 2008 so this is
2008 at the start of this uh the period
of the financial crisis it was up at 4.5
percent and recently look at this line
it started to go up up up and after that
mini budget
it went up there so it's now above four
percent the first time it's been above
four percent since going back to the
financial crisis and of course this
is not trivial because think about it
the government has just committed to
borrowing a lot more money and when you
borrow you pay at the market rate if
you're the government and the market
rate is going up a lot so this is all
relevant to what the government's uh is
thinking about right now I imagine in
fact I get the impression they are very
nervous behind the scenes even though
they don't want to say that explicitly
both at the governments uh both in
Treasury and in the Bank of England
whether or not this is a crisis or not
well I don't know you know when it
doesn't feel like we're necessarily
there yet but it feels like a very
nervous territory actually Ian I would
love to know your take or my youth but
it's a crisis because uh you know you've
been around for a while and it does feel
like unusual times doesn't it